Steven Pinker, thanks for making time to meet
us here at Harvard, still the best university
in the world.
Can you tell us a little bit more about the
interest of your scholarly work?
What is it you are working on, and why?
I'm interested in human nature, and fortunately
that covers many topics.
I have written on everything, from how to
write well to why languages have irregular
verbs, to the historical trends in war, peace,
murder and genocide, to visual cognition:
how we form mental images, how we recognize
shapes and faces.
One of the great advantages of being a psychologist
is that you can write about all of these topics,
because they all have to do with human nature.
There are a few other fields - like philosophers,
or theologians - who also claim to know everything.
What's the difference?
Well, philosophy is very much related to psychology
- it was philosophers who first raised questions
about human nature.
I don't think there is a sharp division between
the field of philosophy and the field of psychology.
There are philosophical questions and psychological
questions: philosophical questions about the
nature of ideas, how they are logically related
to each other.
Psychological questions are more empirical:
how does the human brain come to think certain
kinds of thoughts and have certain kinds of
values?
But in my experience they have all been closely
related.
You have been extremely kind to accept our
invitation to be one of the speakers at the
Nexus conference on November 12th: 'What Will
Save the World'.
You are world-famous, you are very much in
demand, extremely busy; why did you accept
the invitation to come to Amsterdam, to make
time and speak at that conference?
I liked the question - there can be no bigger
question than 'what will save the world'.
I don't think that anything will save the
world in the sense of bringing utopia to Earth,
but I think the world can be improved, and
that will be the version of the question that
I am very much interested in.
I think the world has improved, and can improve
further.
One of the most famous people in the world
of psychology, Sigmund Freud, was much less
optimistic.
If I understand him well, he was especially
interested in the question: 'Why are things
going wrong all the time?'
We will also have religious people at the
conference, and probably they will say it
goes wrong because there is something like
original sin.
On the secular level, Freud will point at
the dark side of human nature.
Why do you think things go wrong so often?
Well, like Freud I do believe that human nature
has a dark side.
I believe that being a member of a civilized
society involves compromises and discontent,
as Freud so famously put it.
I think that aspects of human nature inevitably
come into conflict with aspects in other people.
I don't think that men and women want exactly
the same thing, and I don't think that parents
and children want exactly the same thing.
Even close friends don't always want the same
thing.
There is always tension, there are always
conflicts of interests.
That is why there is great literature, that
is why there is tragedy.
On the other hand, one component of human nature
is the ability to pose and solve problems,
and to communicate our solutions to other
people via language.
Thanks to writing we can accumulate good ideas,
we can try out ways of improving human life,
keep the ones that work and discard the ones
that don't, learn from our mistakes, learn
from our tragedies.
And bit by bit, figure out ways in which we
can minimize the effects of human conflict.
And I think the data show that we've been
doing it.
Another reason that Freud was so pessimistic
was that he was situated in one of the worst
times of human history, the years following
the First World War, which he lived through,
and immediately preceding the Second World
War, he lived to see the 'Anschluss', his
daughter was arrested by the Nazis, he escaped
just in time to spend the last year of his
life in London.
And so he saw the clouds gathering for one
of the worst interludes in human history,
the Second World War.
Indeed, if the world that Freud lived in had
continued, none of us should be an optimist,
because those were dark days indeed.
Of course, there were predictions after the
war that the two World Wars were just the
beginning of an escalating series: World War
3 was inevitable, and it would be even worse
because of nuclear weapons.
We are now more than 70 years after the end
of World War 2 and World War 3 did not happen;
no nuclear weapon has been used since Nagasaki.
The world has become more democratic, more
affluent, more free, more peaceful in these
70 years.
That's no guarantee that it will continue,
no one can prophesy the future, I don't have
the gift of clairvoyance.
But it shows that the kind of doom that many
intellectuals felt after Word War 2 is not
inevitable.
There are actions that we can take that reduce
the risks.